alors je vous préviens il paraît que
dans ce genre d'intervention il faut
soit déclaré ces conflits d'intérêts
donc je suis complique t vous pouvez pas
avoir idée je travaille pour des gens
qui ne s'intéressent pas suffisamment
aux limites d'autres qui s'intéressent
un certaine marge de manoeuvre pour
attaquer les lillois l'a donc je vous ai
mis par souci d'honnêteté les gens qui
te paient et ceux qui ne paient pas ce
que je vais essayer de vous montrer
c'est que le malheureusement aune du
début on va pouvoir l'enlever
on a déjà commencé à l'enlever et qu' il
va bien falloir faire avec
hélas on n'a pas envie c'est clair si
vous regardez l'économie par exemple qui
est l'alpha et l'oméga aujourd'hui de ce
qu'on débat qu'à chaque fois qu'on
compte
quant aux comptes on est bien content et
les oraux c'est un des trucs beaucoup
compté en général on n'a pas envie de
voir des limites donc vous voyez
voilà des gens qui par exemple pense que
la croissance est un truc de long terme
en voilà d'autres qui vous disent que la
croissance est un truc de long terme
et puis encore d'autres et puis encore
d'autres en fait j'ai passé ce matin
très exactement trente secondes sur
internet a trouvé tous ces trucs là je
pense que si j'avais passé une heure je
vous aurai tous sous les tellement nos
rangs devraient trouver je suis en
maître 15-15 transparent donc en fait
les limites c'est clair qu'on n'aime pas
plus ça dans l'économie qu'ailleurs et
la question c'est est-ce qu'on a raison
de raisonner comme ça alors il ya un
fait dont on s'est rendu compte il ya
quelques décennies maintenant quand on a
commencé à s'aventurer hors de la terre
et qu'on a pu la photographier de
l'extérieur on s'est rendu compte que la
terre était chili mais cette fois on
s'en rend vraiment compte en le
regardant oui c'est une boule est alors
non seulement on s'en rend compte mais
en fait on sait que il ya deux siècles
elle faisait cette taille là et puis
aujourd'hui elle fait la même taille et
devant deux siècles elle sera toujours
la même taille
c'est à dire que la probabilité qu'on
puisse souffler dedans pour la gonfler
comme un ballon et avoir un peu plus
d'espacé malheureusement pas très très
élevé donc là on rêve il limite la terre
fait treize mille kilomètres de diamètre
vous allez dire bon très bien quoi cela
me concerne ça nous concerne un tout
petit peu parce que nous sommes de plus
en plus nombreux à vouloir partager
cette boîte de pétri un peu particulière
qui s'appelle la planète terre vous avez
ici l'évolution de la population depuis
que notre planète c'est depuis que notre
espèce pardon s'est sédentarisée alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'on aime bien regarder
la population depuis qu'on est
sédentaire parce que ça a complètement
changé la façon dont on vit
avant des demandes nomades qui se
baladait un peu à droite et à gauche
et soit dit en passant la
sédentarisation des hommes correspond au
moment où le climat devient stable et se
met pendant dix mille ans a ressemblé à
ce qu'il était avant qu'on commence à
tripoter un peu fort donc il ya des
bilans nous sommes quelques millions sur
terre au moment du début de la
révolution industrielle
on est déjà beaucoup plus nombreux mais
enfin vous voyez que ça a évolué
lentement
et puis là en deux siècles on est passé
à plus de 7 milliards d'individus
alors quand vous regardez ce genre
d'évolution tous les gens qui font des
courbes dans la salle il ya peut-être
quelques-uns beaucoup plus qui
s'intéresse aux courbes et bien vous
vous dites pas complètement sûr que ce
truc là soit complètement durable c'est
à dire qu'on veut se stabiliser sur le
niveau de la courbe l'appui on va y
rester pendant des milliers d'années
quelques petits doutes sur le fait que
c'est peut-être ce qui est comme ça que
ça va s'écrire dans le même temps une
des choses que vous savez peut-être
c'est que chacun des bipèdes qui
peuplent la planète c'est vise à
utiliser de plus en plus d'énergie alors
en fait utiliser de l'énergie c'est un
terme parfaitement sains propres
je crois pas qu'il ait une seule
personne dans la salle qui est but du
pétrole en tout cas je vous le
déconseille c'est pas terrible et je
vous déconseille encore plus de mettre
les doigts dans la prise
ça vous fera pas à mixer la soupe donc
quand on dit qu'on utilise de l'énergie
en fait c'est très un propre comme
expression où ça veut dire qu'on utilise
une machine qui elle même va utiliser de
l'énergie donc utiliser de plus en plus
d'énergie ça veut juste dire qu'on se
transforme en superman c'est à dire
qu'on a plus en plus de machines à notre
disposition
ici vous avez l'énergie qui est utilisé
par les hommes alors je vais pas vous
détailler sa longtemps je vais juste
vous donner un multiple quand on regarde
la quantité d'énergie commercial qui en
fait celle qui sert à générer du
mouvement où la force mécanique
donc j'ai enlevé le bois là dedans qui
sera essentiellement est chauffée juste
l'énergie qui sert à générer de la force
mécanique et bien cette énergie a été
multiplié par plus de 20 par individu en
un siècle et demi ce qui est une autre
façon de dire que le parc de machines
par personne le costume d'iron man qu'on
sait tous construits il a été multiplié
par au moins 20 en fait les machines
sont devenus plus efficaces dans le même
temps et il s'est plutôt x 210 autrement
le parc de machines qu'on a aujourd'hui
à la disposition pour transformer tout
ce qui nous entoure
sur cette planète terre c'est comme
s'ils nous avaient poussé 200 paires de
jambes et 200 paires de bras chacun
c'est un peu ça c'est un peu ça l'idée
on s'est tous transformés en shiva
d'une certaine manière et ce qui fait
alors la particularité de l'énergie
c'est qu'en fait on
c'est pas un quelconque en dire quelque
chose qu'on achète de l'énergie c'est ce
qui permet de caractériser le changement
c'est ça qu'il faut avoir qu'il faut
avoir en tête donc l'énergie et du reste
les physiciens ou le répète pour ceux
d'entre vous qui sont passés entre leurs
mains c'est ce qui permet de
caractériser la transformation de
l'environnement de l'énergie c'est
desquels l'énergie qui entrent en jeu
c'est que l'environnement se transforme
cette énergie on ne peut soit dit en
passant qu utiliser celles qu'on trouve
déjà dans la nature parce qu'il ya une
loi 13 ans qui nantes qui a été édictée
par les physiciens il ya très longtemps
que j'appelle la loi de conservation
donc la loi de conservation de vous dit
en gros un truc très simple elle dit
vous n'avez pas le droit de créer de
l'énergie dans un système clos j'ai très
très sain dans un système clos pouvez
pas créer d énergie enfin harry potter
il peut mais vous non donc pour utiliser
de l'énergie
vous êtes obligés d'aller la chercher
dans l'environnement là où elles
existent déjà et vous allez la mettre
dans quelque chose qui sait en faire un
service et ce quelque chose s'appelle un
convertisseur donc en gros pour utiliser
de l'énergie il faut qu'elle soit déjà
dans l'environnement et la mettre dans
un convertisseur alors historiquement on
a un convertisseur sous la main c'est
nous on a une énergie à mettre dedans
c'est la nourriture et on est capable
d'en tirer du travail un peu les corses
un peu moins non pardon j'ai rien dit et
de la chaleur
d'accord c'est ça qu'on est capable d'en
faire historiquement après on se dit
c'est pas mal ce truc là mais c'est
quand même encore un peu limité donc si
on pouvait augmenter ce serait bien
alors on se dit bon on peut utiliser
d'autres convertisseur qu'on a aussi
sous la main par exemple on va
domestiques et des animaux donc ça veut
dire qu'on s'adjoint déjà des premiers
auxiliaires qui vont nous permettre de
faire mieux et plus généralement toutes
les énergies renouvelables que nous
avons réussi à utiliser la force du vent
la force de l'eau etc tous ces trucs là
ont été utilisés non il ya longtemps
dans l'antiquité
et puis il ya deux siècles il ya des
ingénieurs géniaux qui trouvent des
nouveaux convertisseurs qui s'appelle
les machines fait de métal et à ce
moment on va pouvoir leur donner à
manger du pétrole du gaz du charbon et
tout un tas d'autres trucs et on va
pouvoir encore démultiplié notre
capacité à agir sur l'environnement
donc là vous avez très résumée
l'histoire de l'énergie et des hommes
donc ça fait monsieur d'origine n'a rien
inventé ça fait cinq cent mille ans
qu'on est en transition énergétique
et à chaque fois ce qu'on a cherché à
faire c'est à augmenter notre capacité
de transformation de l'environnement
pour pouvoir faire plus de choses et de
machins parce que nous sommes des
animaux au cumulatif
alors une fois que je vous ai dit ça en
gros la quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise
c'est donc la quantité de machines qui
transforme l'environnement et donc au
premier ordre
la quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise
c'est notre facteur de pression sur
l'environnement au premier rendre c'est
vraiment content et l'énergie que
j'utilise ces comptes et la manière ses
comptes et la quantité de transformation
que j'ai depuis dans l'environnement
ce qui fait que la pression de l'homme
sur son environnement c'est la
population humaine qui a évolué comme ça
fois l'évolution de la consommation
d'énergie et donc ça ressemble à peu
près à ça et donc là on comprend qu'il
ya des sujets qu'il ya deux siècles
n'était absolument pas un problème est
aujourd'hui simplement parce que les
ordres de grandeur ont changé ça devient
des problèmes majeurs alors un problème
majeur c'est quoi c'est un truc qui va
pas durer
c'est essentiellement ce à la définition
d'un problème c'est quelque chose que
vous pouvez pas laisser en l'état c'est
à dire que ça finit par se résoudre
soit parce que vous en êtes occupés soit
à vos dépens mais en général un problème
c'est ça ça finit toujours par trouver
une solution quelque part elle est plus
ou moins maîtrisés plus ou moins
sympathiques plus ou moins agréables
la quantité d'énergie par personne et la
population augmentant la pression
globale augmente et donc les
conséquences de cette pression globale
augmente quelle que soit la conséquence
que vous regardez au premier rang brrr
donc il ya plus de co2 dans l'air plus
d'azoté qui se baladent partout plus de
mercure ici plus de plomb la plus de
soufre en plus de ceux ci plus de cela
alors de temps en temps vous avez des
petites corrections qu'on arrive à faire
à la marge d'accord donc on arrive à
faire un peu moins de soufre dans les
sens mais au prix d'un peu plus
d'énergie consommée dans les raffineries
parce qu'il faut des sulfures et les
carburants
un peu moins de jeu pourquoi un peu
moins de trous dans la couche d'ozone
parce qu'on remplace les cfc par
d'autres gaz frigorigènes mais du coup
un peu plus d'énergie pour fabriquer les
glaces enfin bref on en fait on arbitre
les duisans c'est à dire que supprimer
une nuisance on sait jamais faire ce
qu'on sait faire
ces arbitres et pour la remplacer par
une autre qui nous plaît plus en général
c'est ça qu'on fait
alors tout ça on a réussi à le faire et
à considérer que ce n'est pas très grave
parce que il se trouve que dans la
convention économique que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure et qui est celle que vous
avez le plus l'habitude de manipuler
aujourd'hui ce qu'on fait à
l'environnement savons rien ça vaut rien
parce que dans l'économie que vous avez
apprise à l'école on vous a expliqué que
les ressources naturelles était gratuite
c'est un axiome de l'économie classique
vous savez que dans l'économie classique
les deux facteurs de production c'est le
capital humain et le travail humain et
le reste s'est comptée comme étant 0
d'accord donc si on a besoin de
l'environnement pour faire de la
production bas c'est parfait c'est
gratuit donc le fait de abîmé entre
guillemets l'actif de départ qui
s'appelle la terre et que mère nature à
fait gratuitement pour nous en 14
milliards d'années depuis le big bang
c'est ça qui lui a fallu à mère nature
travaille pas très vite donc il faut
attendre le big bang une soupe de
protons une première génération des
toiles qui vous fait tous les éléments
du tableau de mendeleïev puis ça se
balade dans l'espace puis ça fait une
deuxième génération des étoiles ça se
reconcentre il vous faut un système
climatique etc des espèces qui
apparaissent tout ça gratuit on n'a rien
fait donc on est tous étaient des
courses en chef
j'adore les corses et donc on attend
simplement que ça se passe ce que la
recette se base et puis on a raillé puis
on se sert dans ce grand supermarché
absolument génial mais gratuit qui
s'appelle la planète terre et donc quand
on prend dans le supermarché savons rien
d'accord nulle part ça vaut rien alors
on va imaginer si ça valait quelque
chose juste pour que vous avez eu l'idée
vous avez peut-être entendu parler
surtout le cosmonaute qui va vous parler
de la station spatiale internationale
or la station spatiale internationale a
coûté 100 milliards de dollars pour être
construite alors elle sert
essentiellement à monsieur ps qui à
prendre des photos accessoirement à
autre chose 100 milliards de dollars 100
milliards de dollars
et là dedans vous avez pour six
personnes je dis bien pour six personnes
de quoi respirer de quoi boire
partiellement recyclant vos propre urine
eu de quoi appeler houston pour dire que
ça la terre s'est produit dans hop puis
ça s'arrête là et une pression
atmosphérique d'accord à ce prix là vous
n'avez même pas de quoi faire pousser de
carottes les pas de sol vous n'avez pas
le bruit des vagues
vous n'avez pas les lapins qui se
reproduisent et vous n'avez
absolument pas la neige qui tombe
hilaire d'accord vous avez juste
quelques sous-ensembles tout petit tout
petit de ce que mère nature sur terre
nous offrent gratuitement et ça vous
coûte quand même 15 milliards de dollars
par personne
cette histoire donc moi je me dis bon la
planète
ce que la nature nous a donné
gratuitement en fait si le compte est ça
vaudrait au moins 15 milliards de
dollars par personne puisque sur terre
on trouve au moins de quoi respirer on
trouve au moins un cycle de l'eau et
puis en fait on trouve beaucoup d'autres
choses dont 15 milliards de dollars par
personne alors là dessus la question
c'est quelle fraction de ces 15
milliards de dollars par personne qui
est le capital de départ je consomme
chaque année avec mes activités
économiques
envoyé par exemple pour les poissons en
un siècle on a réussi à faire
disparaître 90% de la bio-masse dans
l'atlantique nord sur les espèces qui
sont commercialement intéressant c'est
pas sur tout mais sur les espèces qui
sont commerçants donc ça bah ça vous
donne un rythme de disparition qui est
de l'ordre du pur sang par an après en
ce qui concerne le pétrole
depuis qu'on a commencé à en sortir on a
sorti à peu près la moitié de ce qui
était extractible un peu moins mais
c'est pas grave
donc là vous voyez aussi un rythme
d'amortissement du capital qui est de
l'ordre du pur sang et puis on à
diminuer le stock de forêt on a commencé
à diminuer une partie du stock de sols
cultivables pas une grosse partie
heureusement on a diminué tout ce qu'ils
avaient dans les mines puisque dans les
mines ça se reconstitue pas quand vous
avez une mine de minerai de cuivre quand
vous piochez dans ben il s'est pas pour
autant que le minerai de cuivre se
reconstitue et puis on a pioché
également dans le climat d'une certaine
manière puisque on a commencé à
déstabiliser un système climatique qui
nous allait bien et pour le remettre en
place il va falloir attendre très
longtemps
donc moi ce que je dis c'est admettons
que ce capital on en consomme entre 1%
et 1 pour 1000 par an d'accord à ce
moment ça veut dire que vous avez au
passif économiquement de chaque habitant
sur terre 15 millions de dollars par an
est d'accord avec moi un pour mille de
15 milliards ça fait 15 millions à côté
de ça vous avez une production
économique qui est contée de façon
classique qui vaut 15 mille dollars
par personne et par an donc en fait on
pense que notre activité économique nous
enrichit et moi je vous dis bah c'est
pas complètement sûr parce qu'en fait à
chaque fois qu'on produit 1 ont détruit
1000 dit autrement si j'avais à
reconstituer avec mon travail de l'air
respirable des stocks des espèces etc
en fait je pourrais pas y arriver quoi
donc ce qu'on croit être une bonne
affaire et une croissance économique en
fait une simple simple changement de
convention vous dis bah non en fait
c'est une décroissance
voilà c'était juste un petit alors il ya
des gens qui ont regardé ça depuis
longtemps
il ya quelques dizaines d'années il ya
une bande de dynamicien des systèmes de
haïti qui avait commencé à faire un
modèle world prix qu'ils ont pu égaliser
ou popularisée dans un livre qui a un
peu défrayé la chronique à l'époque qui
s'appelait les limites à la croissance
en anglais très mal traduits en français
et dans lequel il avait fait une
scénarisation de ce qui arriverait à une
humanité qui cherchait à tout le temps
croître sur une planète qui ne voulaient
pas croître alors nous sommes en 1900
ils font tourner leurs modèles en le
faisant partir de 1920 par dante ou
sommes en 1970 et eux ils disent je vais
commencer par faire tourner mon modèle à
partir de 1900 et vérifier que le modèle
il reprend du bien ce qui s'est passé
donc le modèle vous dis ben voilà
jusqu'en 1970 la population augmente la
nourriture par personne augmente la
production industrielle par personne etc
et vous avez tout en haut là en bleu les
ressources restantes dont vous avez un
stock de départ de ressources du pétrole
des minerais etc
évidemment ça diminue un peu avec le
temps alors en 1970 s'accroît en fait
ils disent même pas plus tard ça va
continuer à croître
donc vous voyez jusqu'en 2020 ils disent
une pose problème ça continue à croître
le monde va pas s'arrêter de tourner
mais il dit sauf que tant qu'on cherche
la croissance perpétuelle sur une
planète qui devrait pas croître à un
moment le système s'effondre et vous
avez ce que dans l'en en anglais on
appelle au vote shutenko l'aps c'est à
dire que vous allez au delà des limites
de résilience du système et après
l'autre se casse la gueule alors vous
pouvez dire pas très bien à ce moment je
veux pas et donc je vais me limiter
peut-être sauf que peut-être pas alors
dans les limites qu'on a commencé à
franchir
vous en avez ici une qui est passée
totalement sous l'écran radar des de la
presse française
dans le dernier rapport de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie qui est paru
en décembre 2018
vous avez la phrase en rouge que je vous
invite à lire et à méditer dans laquelle
il est dit la production de pétrole
conventionnel est passé par un maximum
en 2008 donc le pic de production pour
le pétrole non conventionnel ça existe
puisque ça fait dix ans que c'est passé
alors il reste d'autres types de pétrole
etc
mais globalement on n'est déjà plus très
très loin du moment où ce truc qui
alimentent l'économie mondiale va
commencer à faire des choses bizarres
après vous avez un autre problème à
laval qui a également commencé à se
manifester de manière importante qui est
le changement climatique et là je vais
juste vous donner deux indications sur
ce que ça signifie le changement
climatique ici vous avez une carte de
l'europe telle qu'elle s'observe
aujourd'hui si on supprime pas les
écosystèmes installé pour y faire autre
chose donc le forum des images plus tout
un tas d'autres trucs accessoires
deschamps les routes etc
ici vous avez la carte de l'europe telle
qu'elle existait ya vingt mille ans ok
famille là on est au coeur de la
dernière ère glaciaire il est beaucoup
plus froid évidemment l'europe ne
ressemble pas du tout à ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
d'abord il ya pas de tedx en scandinavie
parce que les scandinaves sens où la
glace vous avez un glacier de trois
kilomètres d'épaisseur qui occupe toute
la scandinavie
vous avez la même chose au canada pour
constituer ses glaciers il faut prendre
de l'eau quelque part elle a été prise
dans l'océan le niveau de l'océan et 120
mètres plus bas il fait beaucoup plus
froid et beaucoup plus sec donc l'euro
vous avez le tundra sibérienne en france
et y a pas de quoi faire vivre le forum
des halles qui manque un peu de
consommateurs à l'époque puisque la
population française est limitée à cent
mille personnes
eh bien le passage de l'europe de gauche
à l'europe de droite qui s'est fait
pendant la dernière déglaciation
correspond à une élévation de la
température planétaire de seulement 5
degrés
envoyez le changement climatique quand
on parle de quelques degrés l'élévation
de la moyenne on est vraiment en train
de parler d'un gros choc
donc d'un côté on commence à manquer de
pétrole de l'autre on se prépare un
changement climatique qui est loin
d'être terminée qui essaiera donc payer
les limites à la croissance
en fait on commence à les voir elle
commence à être sous doute n'est
simplement la part affective de notre
cervelle continue à avoir envie de
regarder les indicateurs qui vont bien
histoire que l'on puisse une minute de
plus monsieur le bourreau de ne pas
regarder la situation telle qu'elle
commence à se présenter mais voilà
malheureusement les limites elles sont
déjà là et pour les plus jeunes d'entre
vous dans cette salle donc ça c'est la
partie très très mauvaise nouvelle
elles vont s'appliquer de manière
croissante jusqu'à ce que vous vouliez
mon âge et bien plus parce que
malheureusement la terre neuve est
toujours que 13,8 km de diamètre
voilà merci